[Music]
hey yo it's pillpod we are podcasting
messages of hope and delusion
into the void flick your balls a little
bit it's your friday critical theory or
philosophy or hour of lib takes podcast
depending on your perspective although
we are down a lib today it is i victor
and eric
hello
i am outnumbered by the radicals the
postmodern neo-marxist your daddy warned
you about more radical
how's the mood how's the temperature i
don't i don't really want updates on
your life but i'm personally i'm in one
of my bi-annual depressive states um and
i think it was caused by watching the
matrix and spider-man
but they were that bad eh
also all the trailers before spider-man
which were a hundred percent for sequels
or remakes
that's the future i get i get the matrix
but what's got you down about spider-man
mostly that they
there are no films anymore there's
nothing the films are gone we're just
left with content and i am asked to like
it
and enjoy it by who
by you know the big other
i see
i did not the compelled enjoyment of
mediocrity well you know the premise
right well no sony just used all of
their ip to try to make like a a marvel
thing and even though half of those
spider-man movies suck balls uh
we're supposed to like them when they're
all in the same movie together i don't
know man i don't watch any of these
superhero movies the only superhero
movies i watch are like the batman ones
when it was dark knight
and this new one i guess i don't know
who the it's who's the new batman in the
new trailer i don't know it's that i
think i think i have a movie guy yeah
right right i have just like a weird
snobby attitude that i just i'm above
superhero movies so i don't watch them i
think uh into the spider verse is
definitely worth a watch but i haven't
seen the new one
but that one leaves you on a kind of
hopeful note i don't know about this new
one i think boycotting superhero movies
is what i have to do like i i feel the
compulsion because
that is
the thing that you talk about in the
public commons and we have so so few
avenues of public comments that
superhero movies are
one of the main
publics that we have i guess so is that
true yeah i guess it is i don't know i
mean privatize we don't have a political
landscape particularly in
lockdown but even outside of lockdown so
superhero movies and like the super bowl
a few of those things are the things
that i participate in against my better
judgment but i think uh i think it's
super bowl you participate in that i
think i always watch it
really
i didn't know that for the commercials
that's kind of the only sport i watch
all year is just the super bowl
football that's funny i had no idea that
you watched any of that stuff i feel
like you've never you've never said that
out loud or i've never heard you say
that out loud
oh that sounds familiar this being
infantilized
maybe maybe that's just what it's like
to be 30 but the infantilization of
everything
but both already talked about this in
1980 so maybe it's not how how come you
by the way how come you don't like the
new the new season of the expanse like
i've been watching it and i think it's
fine but i remember last episode you
just said you hate it is that another
thing contributing to your depressive
state
they pulled a game of thrones
like like game of thrones
it drew through
it drew from good source material
and then the first few seasons were more
careful about drawing from the source
material and what made it good
now the expanse is just a plot show and
the plot isn't even that good the the
nuances of politics the characters
motivations all of that is just gone now
for some reason so
maybe because they're rushing it i guess
because they're trying to like finish
the the show i guess i don't know like
there there's like what
nine books in that series and they're on
i don't know what season it is six so i
don't even know why they're opting to
rush it maybe it's not popular enough
but yeah maybe
we've already done some stuff on
superheroes
yeah back back when we were talking
about phenomenology i think it
definitely improved my state of mind and
now i'm just back on my phone and
looking at what there is to talk about
and despite our best intentions it
appears we'll all just
tread water in ideology fluid until we
die
i saw someone post i saw someone tweet
um
most podcasts are too long
um and i wonder what we think about that
most podcasts in general or most of ours
are too long just in general just in
general this person was commenting on
that i don't and i wonder what the i
mean i feel like the hour 15 that we
usually hit
seems like a reasonable number
um but why would you feel like you had
to listen to the whole thing is this
like a the compulsion of the commons
that i just brought up that you have to
finish it if you're bored
go find another podcast i will say that
i think that there's something
but sometimes i do feel like i'll see
like some podcast episode come out or
some discussion and it'll be like two
hours and a half and i'm just like
it makes me like not want to start it's
like in some ways there's just like
i think there's an intuitive appeal to
like looking and being like
it's it's realistic for me to be able to
fit that in and finish it right but to
be like well i'll start it and then like
if i get through it i'll just move on if
not i'll move on that's not as appealing
right like when i see it in my like feed
there's a nice there's a there's an
intuitive appeal to being like i can
complete this like a completionist
appeal
but if i see something that's like too
long it's like it's a disincentive from
even starting it right it's like i don't
want to start this thing that's three
hours like what like
like when am i i'm just not even gonna
start it right so sure i think three
hours is too long but by the same token
when i see an episode that's 30 minutes
i'm also disincentivized to click on it
because i agree 30 minutes
i can't imagine there'd be much
substance in something like that unless
it's really really tight and quick i
would i would like some feedback from
the audience about optimal lengths i do
think that we're pretty much hitting
that sweet spot but i just i just
thought i would bring it up since i saw
that
our conversation kind of dictates the
length it's almost like we're done
talking at an hour and 15
75 minutes yeah the material is kind of
we just we just go hey if we said
everything we want to say okay it's
getting long anyway but it depends on
the format too right with them we have a
conversational podcast where we need to
fit three or four people's ideas into a
segment so i mean it shakes out to about
an hour 15.
but you know my listening habits are
different right i put things on while
i'm doing things like for instance i
like to listen to
like audio books through podcasting and
then i listen to uh david harvey's
marxist lectures on on capitol and
they're about two and a half hours so i
throw one on i go shopping i don't sit
down and be like this is what's going to
entertain me for the next hour and a
half i do yes at the same time which is
how i assume
is a major way people listen to podcasts
if you're just sitting there listening
to it as a form of entertainment then
you get the same complaints about movies
oh that movie was too long that movie
was too short i felt like they could
have cut that down a bit
it's it's it's true depends on the
format really like maybe for our podcast
how long is a good time for this kind of
podcast no no i mean i i agree i think i
mean i also fit in my my listening
habits kind of in the same way but it's
just i'm usually not
out and about especially now with like
more lockdowns
that long so it's nice to be able to
like have an episode that i can finish
in that time usually or at least be
close to finishing it hey it's anything
you're doing laundry you're cleaning
dishes you're walking the dog you throw
on your headphones in a podcast boom if
it's two and a half hours then you get a
lot of work done maybe accidentally fall
into a twitter hole or something
all right regardless of what you are
doing
listener
laundry
walking your dog today we are looking at
a new word
we like to think of ourselves as your
academic proxies
so we're gonna start with a bit of
academic critique
but the new word for the day is
techno-feudalism which has been
making its way around coming out of yani
vroofakas's mouth
yeah yeah yes
yes
giannis is how you say it
yeah giannis
former former um finance minister of
greece during the financial crisis oh i
totally thought yani was the greek
pronunciation of that i thought you were
just being cheeky and giving him a
little nickname there shortening his
name you're like good old yani me and
yani were good friends that could be
like
insider pronunciation
i think in greece in greek in the greek
language they pronounce their their hard
ass there at the end they don't i don't
think they would they would do silent i
s at the end all right well i apologize
for being
phonetically ignorant
well it's a new word techno-feudalism
and speaking of new words
a lot of the [ __ ] like trying to read
new journal articles this is a bit of a
personal frustration of mine
is
so many
writers trying to
make a name or be cutting edge by making
up words and throwing them against the
wall and hoping they stick and like
catch on and it's tr if they do catch on
you kind of have a career if enough
people are are citing you that's one of
the measures of academic success so
coining the right word at the right time
is a [ __ ] great
career move but these days it's adding a
lot of
prefixes like neo hyper post to words to
freshen them up
neo-materialism is one that i
i came across lately and i don't know
why it's neo-materialism as opposed to
just materialism was there a problem
with old materialism
or
hyper object i know eric you like the
term hyper object but
is it really required i'm not sure it's
doing the citations collection work yeah
well i think i think it's pretty good um
in terms of new materialism right that's
it's a kind of new uh it's it's a new
theoretical paradigm that's coming out
of um
people like you know exploring
post-marxist post-liberal culture there
you go discourses right adding posts
well i'm using it as a kind of temporal
thing i guess because you know
post-marxism would be you know what
about meta-marxism where's meta-marxism
at i don't even give a [ __ ] about meta
stuff i guarantee you if you search that
it's a thing post marxism is just like
kind of moving past marxism trying to
look at other theorists and trying to
move past the sort of marxist framework
whether or not you agree that's a
worthwhile endeavor is besides the point
that's
just giving the name to the new movement
old name new movement why don't you just
take marx's name off of it then but new
materialism specifically focuses on like
the non-discursive and the bodily and
the phenomenological
and it puts emphasis on different things
marks itself out as a new paradigm you
can read collections of books right now
that are written about it do you see
this a lot in political theory victor
i'm sure i mean i guarantee that if i
search in
hyper hyper democracy there's gonna be
something that comes up i mean there
there is
so i just searched i just searched meta
marxism by the way and i found the
abstract to a chapter in some book and
it's like examination of any total
explanation of all that is is is faces
seemingly uh in insuperable difficulties
insuperable is that
is that a word
yeah
insuperable difficulties multiplied in
the present instance by the claim uh to
do so in the context of the interplay of
the four principle streams of
contemporary thought the inside examiner
can be trapped by the totality of the
explanation and by his commitment to the
view in question the outsider can be
accused of dogmatism by i think that's
important
see here's the problem that is not that
is not an explanation
of what of what meta-marxism is that's
that's weird also all the ones with
post-modernism
those are the most blatant because
there's post-post-modernism
trans-post-modernism digi-modernism
pseudomodernism altar modernism and now
meta-modernism is something that some
group is trying to make happen and a few
people have asked me about it just don't
worry about it okay post-modernism is
not done if it even started modernism
was not modern anyway so yeah people we
should just call it all logos was wrong
all along
i think people also just enjoy like i
guess
there's an there's there might just be a
kind of pleasure associated with with
term coinage
um and like the and you know some of it
might be aesthetic some of it there
might be some utility to it in the sense
that like you're putting your thumb on
on like a very nuanced
specific way of of of identifying a
phenomenon although broadly i would say
i'm sympathetic to your kind of
um intuition pills that there's there's
also something
kind of
like yeah i don't know what
it is there there does sometimes you get
an odor of like oh i'm just trying to
find my space there's like an incentive
i guess to be unique in academia and to
be like i've coined something right so
that there is that incentive as well you
know there's one term
this is cut like kind of tangentially
related but
sometimes i find it irritating
or puzzling the way words from academia
end up getting co-opted in certain kind
of activist spaces so one observation
i've had and you know i would actually
love
kind of an audience member to correct me
on this but
has anybody noticed that when like
leftist like blm protesters or or like
people who are who are involved in
anti-racism right and as someone myself
i'm obviously sympathetic and support
anti-racism but i notice that there's
this way in which they talk about black
bodies
right they'll say like black bodies
instead of black people
and i don't know if anyone else like and
i feel like that's from academia that's
like some foucaultian thing that came
over from like the way bodies are
treated by like power structures
biopolitics
but i find it
i guess i just find it puzzling because
it seems so dehumanizing to me like
shouldn't we in our discourse be
talking about black people
not black bodies like i don't understand
so somebody explained to me sort of like
the i would love to hear like an
explanation for why
it's more humanizing or like furthers
anti-racism to talk about black bodies
instead of black people i don't know
it's confusing it's because you're a lib
that's why
yeah it's because they're not
emphasizing the person
personality personal logical right those
are those are liberal concepts those are
bourgeois concepts they're emphasizing
materiality of the body
the
embodiment
that is required of every consciousness
to be embodied
but also the way that the body can be
inscribed like a surface with meaning
right you know like
marginalized peoples are marginalized
bodies because of certain
features certain ways they look
certain things like that
so when you're talking about bodies
i guess you're you're you're adopting
that sort of yeah yes foucaultian kind
of theoretical heritage but it has a use
it has a point as talking about persons
would be assuming like a liberal subject
and that's not what we want to do well i
mean
i understand the theoretical utility but
i but i don't understand the kind of
like activist utility
well from the position like the
foucaultian position
this
the state that you're dealing with or
the power discourse wouldn't see the
people they would see bodies so i think
you're kind of right in that it it's
meant to be dehumanizing so that you can
analyze the vision that the state has of
bodies
but i don't think you would
yeah
you're pointing out a paradox you
wouldn't call yourself the body because
that is the same dehumanizing that the
state originally
performed well that's the thing so
that's exactly my point like so i
understand like the theoretical point
about like the way the state like see
but it's just funny to hear activists
who they're in presumably their whole
goal is to like humanize is to like
bring back but they continue to talk
about
like people being marginalized as bodies
and it's just strange to me because
shouldn't the goal like the kind of
activist utility be
to like actually humanize and raise up
and like stop perpetuating this
phenomenon or whatever so i don't know
it's just it just seems
strange to me and that's where like i
feel like there's a bleed from academic
discourse
and it's like oh you're just like doing
the thing that you're criticizing in a
way like inadvertently i mean i'd like
to see we can we have to put a pin in
this because if you're going to
interpret something you actually have to
have an example in front of you and just
because the term is used doesn't mean
yeah yeah no but
exactly what it's used for
but there is an activist position which
would be to describe yourself as the way
that the state describes you
self-reflexively
which would be to account for your
experience
by
the way that you are not the way you see
yourself as a person but by the way
you are disciplined
and the interpolation of that would
imply the critique so i i don't think
that would be an incorrect usage i mean
it's a theoretical point right all
language is theoretically laden and when
you're doing you're doing activism right
you need theory to guide your actions
just like when you go into the market to
buy things you
generally have a theory of how the
market works and how you can get what
you want out of it it doesn't make sense
to say to go into somewhere without a
theory of what's going on or about how
to address the issues
so i mean the sorts of things that
activists choose from the theory world
that's most conducive to their activity
tends to be the language of materiality
right which
takes the form of bodies in the fukodian
heritage or if you're a marxist
it takes the form of of
labor
which is a productive activity which
again involves materialism right so it
emphasizes the materialism instead of
dematerializing people by referring to
them as subjects or persons or minds or
whatever right you materialize because
it's the material conditions that
determine whether or not a person can be
free whether or not a person will be
considered a person in the first place
right so bodies is a is a kind of yes
it's theoretically laden but it also
guides the activities to put it to put a
pin in it i just i found like a i just
did a quick google search i found like a
medium.com article
from i i don't know
aisha c i think i'm not sure if she if
sh what else she's written but like she
has a think piece that just says can we
stop referring to black people as black
bodies please
so i guess i'm not the only one who's
had who's made that observation um
the words we have haven't accomplished
so much but if we invent some more it
doesn't cost anything to do it
uh fallow capitalism we don't have that
one yet i don't think do we
fallow capitalism
oh my god i just searched it we do have
fallow capitalism of course we have that
i was referring to uh like
derrida did this to great success and
fame and and fortune
maybe so i it's like he he's part
partially responsible for this
phelogocentrism is one of the
grievous
why don't we just do ad-libs we can just
do ad-libs where we combine a prefix
with like a critical theory word and
then you have to come up with the
definition of it there's like neo
fallow
super
meta
actually
no let's just do this right now i'm
gonna go
we'll do add capitalism pragmatism
subjectivity
fascism and then you have to come
i'm gonna go get a d6 actually hold on
i'm gonna make you i'm gonna make you
come up with the definition of a word
oh my god this is like kind of like a
poetry word game
and we'll just let them cut out the uh
part where he's going to get stuff
yeah
all right
this
this is actually happening okay
so i got a bunch of words here sorry
i'll just cut out i'll just cut this bit
out
um
eric you have to do the first word
actually i'll go okay i'll give all
three of us a word and then you have to
come up with a definition on the spot
all right roll that
your word is neo is the prefix
fascism never mind don't do that when
that one sucks neal fashion don't do
that one that was too easy
okay uh
fallow
fallow pragmatism is your word
follow pragmatism uh victor while you're
thinking i'll give victor his that i'll
do it for myself yours is neo
fascism also [ __ ]
the dice really i'll skip that one
um
super
subjectivity
okay you got to get it okay you got to
get into that whitehead whitehead
actually already
uh cyber that's a good start good
cyber structuralism
i mean
in a way follow follow pragmatism
kind of an easy one
because all the practices i could think
of
before uh
raw or uh before uh i don't know are all
males oh so this is a feminist critique
of it's it's a critical tradition yeah
it's a critical
word for the uh patriarchal origins of
pragmatism
especially that of rorty and dewey
because they impose a kind of cultural
relativism on us that's secretly a uh a
uh hyper-patriarchal view of of use and
and pragmatic action yeah there you go
the pragmatic is embedded in there as
man is the active subject woman as the
passive subject in the andro scene
follow pragmatism reigns
nice i see this is not even difficult
now you have like a dissertation chapter
super subjectivity um yeah so to figure
this out i was like trying to find the
etymology of super to see like if i
could if i could come up with anything
based on that
and i see that it's above or
above or beyond to great extreme degree
um
yeah above beyond exactly that's the
main thing so i guess like i would say
that super subjectivity
is
like the ongoing process
with which our
subjectivity becomes interfaced with i'm
gonna i'm gonna like apply it maybe like
a cybernetic lens to it but there's
probably another word that identifies
this but i guess like
uh super subjectivity is like the
subjectivity of of all of us being
connected
through like the new subjectivity that
emerges as a result of our interaction
with each other through these mediums oh
kind of like a super organism and a
super subject
so it's like this it's like the result
of i guess maybe when
the interaction of subjectivities
through cybernetic
uh platforms
because becomes somehow self-conscious
of itself that's like the super
subjectivity so cyber is cool cyber
super subjectivity
yeah it's like the way that the modern
media knits together all of our
subjectivities into a single entity that
reacts exactly together
whitehead does actually have a term
called the superject
oh really what does that mean
that's that's closer to a universal idea
well we call the subject he calls the
superject because for him even any sort
of interaction involves two subjects
but we could also say that the super
subjectivity could just be like
another another word for hegel's like
absolute
super subject okay and i have to do
cyber structuralism
um
with cyber structuralism that's good
with the critiques of structuralism
by
jacques derrida and roland bart there
have been many new interesting
connections
made
okay i'm trying to present this i can't
i can't keep going with this
i think we can use cyber structuralism
to
evaluate
the cybernetic
production of communities
in
spaces that are mediated by
technology
um and we can
observe that all all online communities
are
based on three levels of unconscious
expression
beginning at the bottom with the
zooanthropes so the cat people the cat
boys
that's the animal
then the
the imaginary
the imaginary will be the second layer
of human consciousness
embodied by the
anime avatars
and finally did we put at the top
the sig the sigmas
the sigma's the sigma is because it's a
greek letter expresses the linguistic
aspect of human consciousness so there
we go
that is a cyber structure i decided that
levy strauss would be proud
actually i decided that super
subjectivity is really just another like
an academic way of identifying the sigma
see we have a new unified theory and it
only took us
six dice rolls and ten minutes
because it's beyond because sigma is is
beyond the categorization right it like
doesn't fit into the into this into the
spectrum so it's just the remainder
beyond
the xs
that's a fun game everybody coin coin
your own terms that is a fun game
we should do that every day we should do
that every week we should start the show
like the uh the walrus things in south
park you just choose the balls and then
make something up based on what comes
out it's a perfect family guy
episode yeah
gary coleman
all right why don't we get to our
neologism of
the day today which is techno feudalism
we watched a lecture and techno
feudalism is giannis verofakis word
for something that's concurrent with
capitalism
um i'm just going to insert the clip so
we don't have to rehash that i think
it's good to just wait now as a way are
you as a segue do are you interrupting
before the clip or after the clip
uh either one okay you just you decide
based on what i say which is that as a
kind of segue into talking about
techno feudalism from capitalism i just
evoke
actually
jijek's sort of opening
for that is that the public use of
reason is under threat that's the kind
of that's the kind of um
uh uh
emblem of the talk is that public use of
reason is under threat and the private
use of reason is on the rise
and i think that's a great way to
distinguish useless neologisms from
useful neologisms is that are they made
in the service of public reason to help
people understand or are they made for
private gain or to reinforce
existing structures and existing
institutions are they a kind of method
of you know economic calculation
the way we
you know coin new terms to get ahead in
the academic rat race the way we coin
buzzwords to make our products seem more
appealing and those sorts of ideas are
the ways that economists and law and and
and jurists will come up with terms to
you know
make a ridiculous process like money
printing sounds like something good like
quantitative easing when it really just
means printing [ __ ] money and nothing
else is it being used in the sense of
private reasoning or public reasoning as
could you
define like the public use of reason in
this context yeah the public use of
reasoning is a distinction comp made so
public use of reasoning is different
from private use of reasoning if you
watch the video i don't really need to
rehash it because this is gjx opening
but public use of reasoning
is in good kantian way when you're
reasoning according to the laws
prescribed by rationality right when
you're a rational individual
you don't require
the say you're you're out of your
immaturity of your reasoning you don't
need to be led by others you think for
yourself in kantian terms you know it's
it's the self-prescription of laws by
rationality right you prescribe your own
laws and you accord to them you don't
let other people tell you what to do and
when public reasoning comes along right
in the kantian sense this is because
you're having an opening discussion
you're having an open discussion
with the public and public intellectuals
involved in
it's it's like real talk right as
opposed to private reasoning which is
interested this is supposed to be
disinterested reasoning
right
and private reasoning is something that
you know if you're a clergy member the
church will determine things that you
can say and cannot say and for kant
that's fine as long as you can also have
public reasons yeah it's worth adding to
that this was like a distinction that
rawls also ran with like the whole point
of rawls theory of justice was to
determine principles that could be
consistent with public use of reason
because laws are inherently coercive
right you cannot make a just society
based on laws you have you cannot coerce
people as i've been learning about you
cannot coerce people into being good you
can lead a horse to water but you can't
make them drink whatever but
what those laws have to do is almost be
in internalized and reconfirmed in the
individual mind through a process of of
of critique right critic critiquing the
tools of cognition and consciousness and
logic right and then
so you can't coerce people you have to
you have to
lead people into the growth that they
need to
have in order to become a reasonable
mature
self-sufficient individual in in the
kantian sense
as opposed to leading people by the hand
which is private reasoning you know i
prescribe my reasons
wait i need to get to this clip
we're gonna get to the clip
okay can we do that first
this is techno feudalism
the point is is a
neologism coined in the interest of
public reason not private reason like
buzzwords or fashionable nonsense or
whatever other crap like that's all we
were saying with all that okay anyway
techno feudalism what is it
it means the end of capitalism in one
sense but it's also concurrent with
capitalism in another sense here is
giannis explaining it
insert
there is something tremendous happening
now in capitalism it's no longer the old
market profit productivity and so on
it's no no longer capitalism
can you develop this yeah
since 2008 the great uh financial crash
capitalism is on a drip feed
it's being kept alive
through
constant injections of money from the
central banks
that has never happened before it
started in 2008. in 1929 it didn't
happen that's why all the banks closed
down
so the banking system and the stock
exchange
had 12 years of getting used to being
becoming addicted to central bank money
being pumped their way
during difficult moments
it's my crazy theory that
capitalism has already evolved out of
itself
we it has been transformed into another
system
and the reason why i say that is because
for me capitalism requires two things
firstly
profit to drive it it's like you know a
petrol engine that needs petrol
capitalism needs profit private profit
to drive capital accumulation as we
marxist used to say okay and the other
thing is that exploitation takes place
in markets that's the whole point about
capitalism
in feudalism there wasn't there was no
market exploitation you had the peasants
they were growing rubbish with wheat and
potatoes and cauliflower i don't know
what it is that they were growing and
then the
sheriff on behalf of the lord would come
and take half of it or sixty percent of
it there was no market it was just
expropriation
it is with the enclosures and the
eviction of the peasants who then become
suppliers of labor at any price
that you have the creation of the
working class and the labor market
because no labor market before that
okay
so my exploitation takes place through
markets money markets land markets house
markets
labor markets
but now after 12 years of the 2008
crisis and beyond we have the
replacement of profit
by central bank money
that is in the new fuel of the system of
this exploitative system
and the steady encroachment into the
space of markets
of platforms
amazon
the moment you go into amazon or
facebook the moment you enter facebook
you're outside of capitalism you're not
in capitalism anymore
you and god explain
yeah you go into facebook right
let's say you want to to sell your stuff
to you
advertise your business in facebook
you
go in you pay you use your credit card
you pay money to zuckerberg
and some more people see your your
advertisements
you go in there to meet your friends
uh you want to advertise
this
this evening
you're going to pay money one person
owns the whole digital space it is the
equivalent
of stepping outside in ljubljana imagine
yeah just science fiction for a moment
imagine you step out in ljubljana on the
streets of lubiana today
and you look around and you think oh my
god
all these buildings belong to one person
everything that is traded in the shops
that i see
is controlled by one person who decides
what prices are charged what prices are
not charged who can trade who can't
trade who can buy who can't buy and
moreover imagine that ljubljana operated
like facebook does or amazon does
whereby
what your eyes see
is determined by one person by the
algorithm of one person who if he wants
you not to see something you will never
see it in that digital space this is not
a market this is a thief a system it's a
digital system it's a platform those
platforms make a lot of money
um so the left has been desperately
trying to bring capitalism down
but he says they ran out of time
capitalism brought itself down or at
least is in the process of bringing
itself down
we are left here with the question of
the market because the market still
exists in certain cases
and i guess the point here is that
uh
the bottom rung
the proletariat or the prokaryote
do not have any access to the market
because they don't have any assets so
they become the people that are
exploited by monopolistic corporations
that own
own an entire space that there's no
access to for everybody for anybody else
and they profit off your every click
your every view they get to show you ads
all day they know what you're thinking
where you are et cetera et cetera you're
basically working with uh providing
value
with a form of labor that is not
traditionally labor
yeah i mean he
the capitalism and
market exploitation
under this techno feudalist claim is
that you know capitalism is on life
support markets are on life support they
survive
since 2008 they survive solely on
enormous cash injections from the
central banks
and
what capitalism formally ran on as we
heard capitalism runs on two things
private profit and market exploitation
and private profit is dropping off
the laboring class is shrinking
and on the other hand
and on the other hand um
the new the central banks have taken on
a a completely different role
and they are supporting
markets which are on life support but
what we're seeing is the incursion of
platforms into market space platforms
are coming in and taking over so when
you go on facebook you're not in
capitalism anymore that's the claim
right on facebook you're not in
capitalism anymore you're outside of
capitalism because you're on a platform
and and again it becomes more like a
feudal
system there because some one person
owns everything you see
and in fact determines in this case what
you do and don't see
and they determine what you can and
can't buy who can buy who can't buy and
every and they get a cut of every single
transaction that happens
on their platform it's completely
according to janus is outside of
capitalism because it's a platform which
is coming to replace markets so you
don't have those two things from
capitalism anymore you don't have market
exploitation because nothing is
profitable anymore and the labor in
class is shrinking which is the key
market the labor market of capitalism
and you have the
incursion of platforms replacing
traditional markets and those
traditional markets which are still
around are surviving only on these
enormous cash injections from central
banks
and he describes the kind of dynamics of
those cash injections and the way they
just sort of further impoverish people
who already don't have the buying power
right and and not to mention the the
after 2008 right this is the situation
massive cash injections and platforms
which as you remember you know facebook
twitter
youtube all those major platforms today
are are were born in the mid 2000s right
just before the big crash so just in
[ __ ] time
yeah i mean i think there was a really
interesting account i really like
varifocus i find him
um very likable and like his i find his
points to be like really insightful
in terms of like defining it as in or
out of capitalism
i mean i find i guess it reminds me
there there is like
sometimes a kind of
desire i find among theorists although i
guess he's technically an economist and
not a not a theory he's a he's a marxist
economist just like marx was marx was
marx and he was an economist right right
um like to kind of like the the urge to
like define a new age like now we're
leaving this age into this new age like
i don't know i guess
he the the couple of examples he has
like so one thing that i found kind of
interesting and i by the way i read a
little article that he wrote also
for
project syndicate where he kind of also
goes on to define
technofeudalism
um
but one of the things that i guess i was
a bit confused about is he like the main
example he uses is like facebook and
google but then he also mentions amazon
and like i guess but then he doesn't
explain how like amazon applies to that
same thing because like i get how
there's like certain platforms that we
all use like twitter
um facebook
they control everything that we use
um but then like i don't really
understand how like amazon's not just a
capitalist like i don't understand how
how amazon is also technofutilist and i
didn't notice him explain that he just
kind of mentioned it and bunched it up
with these other things and it seems a
bit different to me isn't it just like
amazon is the same thing it's a platform
when you go on to amazon you're not in a
mall you're not in a free market you're
in a completely different place you're
not in a market you're on a platform
and it's not you know laws and
legislation by some central body that
determines the platform's rules it's a
single person it's jeff bezos who
determines what you see what you don't
see what you can buy what you can't buy
et cetera et cetera it's the same thing
the thing is amazon amazon has
competitors yeah though so i i agree
with what you're saying it's yeah you
can you can still buy from uh
yeah or just ebay or just like alibaba
you can buy from you can buy from i'm
thinking sales stores but they're all
like particular to canada or north
america so i don't wanna
yeah like well best buy are they
competitors though i mean
i mean i think ebay is a significant
competitor so like so is i mean i think
a lot of these different retailers are i
mean walmart you can buy online i mean
it's true like if anything
i would say that amazon is becoming like
a bit monopolistic but that's still like
a part of capitalism right like like
being a monopoly is
a capitalist phenomenon
right so so i don't you know oh look at
the liberal is quoting lenin
thank you very much victor and anyway
this is the point
um
what he's saying is like when you're
when you're on the platform the platform
becomes the dictator of everything that
happens within that platform rather than
the market so on amazon
it's a fiefdom it's not the only fiefdom
that exists but once you're within
amazon then every decision that can be
made there
is made by
amazon's directors
yeah it's like those
those old brick and mortar stores like
amazon i mean not like amazon like
walmart what you were saying
i mean those are still capitalist spaces
but
even even when you shop online and buy
stuff from whatever
walmart best buy or whatever online
you're still kind of
being routed through
a capitalist system
and with i guess with amazon it's it's
completely different
right because they own the platform they
own the means of transportation they own
the supply lines they own everything
from like the point of consumption right
back to the almost right back to the
point of production and even when you
have control of the point of production
amazon can do basically whatever they
want they set the terms not the
producers
yeah but even then it still seems like
there's something to the idea that it's
not a market it's a platform there's a
distinction to be made there
and we should be clear it's not like
capitalism has disappeared it's just
that we have capitalism plus this other
thing and here's a bit of a life support
here's a bit of a provocative question
um what
with the neologism thing is the techno
required here or is all feudalism
already
technofutilism
the techno here just means it's managed
by phone data specifically but feudalism
is never non-technological whether you
own all the good horses
while the church keeps everyone
distracted or you own all the good
servers while ariana grande keeps you
distracted it's sort of the same
mechanism now
yeah maybe maybe techno is not the
greatest term maybe neo-feudalism i
don't know just put two at the end
of the subjectivism
it's like
something
again
let's just put the whole word there
right something new we don't know what
it quite what it is yet but it seems
like it's not capitalism and it's has
very similar traits to feudalism from
before capitalism like that's the that's
being contracted into one word techno
feudalism right so what
i i what i find i think like
i guess i guess like the difficulty i
have with with these kinds of like
coining new ways of talking about or a
new age
is that like i end up getting a bit
fixated on like well what's the
definition of feudalism what's the
definition of capitalism and then like
is it really the same as the and then
it's like well and then i i and then i
all of a sudden kind of snap out of it
and i'm like who cares like the
phenomenon he's pointing out like makes
sense right like like that is happening
like people are
so like i guess on the one hand like i
agree with what he says about how this
is sort of like changing our economy and
like
but then but i don't know if i agree
like and i also don't care
if it is feudalism or if it is like who
cares like it kind of reminds me of the
thing i i was
i i kind of harp on often like back when
there was that whole discussion about
whether trump is a fascist or not and
it's like everyone wants to call him a
fascist and it's like who gives a [ __ ]
just like point to the specific things
that he does that are bad and condemn
those and it's like here is if feudalism
is it not like i kind of think who gives
a [ __ ] let's just point out the shitty
things that are happening specifically
so that we can analyze them and make
sense of them i don't think the term is
that useful and i don't find myself i
feel i feel agnostic and somewhat
unconvinced
that it really is something new and i
also just don't think it matters no i
think it's pretty important i mean i'm
always saying you know we shouldn't
fetishize definitions
but at the same time they're important
because
it acts like you know
what lechon caller puente capitan kind
of brings all of these forces into
relief and gives them a kind of unity
and if they don't really have it then
then maybe future critique will
you know hone the concept or change it
to reflect reality a little bit better
but i mean what we define things all the
time based on you know when what is the
age of majority when are you an adult
right is that not an important
definition
is it not important if that girl you're
trying to sleep with is 15 years old or
18 years old i guess it doesn't matter
because definitions just go out the
window right what is a child really
right that's just a definition no no no
no no no no well yeah yeah yeah i mean
it's it's
flippant obviously i don't think that's
i don't think that's a
but that's completely different that's
not it that's every day life and not
theory but i don't see a big no no no no
no no no no here's the difference the
difference is that
we are in the business
of being like academic theoreticians we
are in the business of observing
phenomena and making sense of them
and i guess my worry with these labels
is that like so feudalism being able to
call something new feudalism has a
rhetorical power
it has a rhetorical appeal
because it's like something that was bad
that we got beyond and then people can
kind of feel good and be like oh yeah
like of course facebook and you know
google they're feudalistic and it's like
you know we feel good and about like
about condemning them for that but then
like i guess what i feel gets lost which
is more important
it's like well what is the specific
phenomenon that we're worried about so
like let's talk about the way that like
now because everyone relies on these
platforms
it like creates these a kind of like a
kind of catch-22 where it's like how do
we get out of them like so i just feel
like talking at the level of specificity
is just better and i and i worry about
the rhetorical appeal of these terms
that kind of you can just be like oh
yeah of course they're all feudalistic
like it's just i don't know it just
seems in when we're in the business of
analyzing of getting like a deep account
of what's of social economic political
phenomena it's better to just
dwell in the level of specificity why
would that worry you though people get
behind words
not
not academic definitions rhetoric
because essential part because it's
because it's ideal because it's it's
ideology because it risks like
ideological mystification like so where
you where it obscures the specificity of
the phenomenon
like i think that happens react to
rhetoric they don't react to specificity
all discourses has rhetoric as a
rhetorical component like that's just
that's just like
as academics i feel like we should be
who are you calling an academic like so
it depends what context we're in right
so like in the political activist
context where like we want to win hearts
and minds i get the utility of like
calling it feudalism
but like in the business of just like
trying to get an accurate account of
social political economic phenomenon i
don't know how important it is all right
like to be able to take it point taken
let's stop talking about talking and
actually do what you're suggesting one
second
yeah one second let me just one point
about rhetoric okay so you know
the three kinds of rhetoric right of
course what aristotle says he appeals
to our pathos he appeals to ethos he's
an authority on the subject he's but
that there's a third appeal and it's
called logos is a rhetorical appeal and
you repeal appeal to reasons and he
spends the next hour after that clip
giving you all of the logos of this
rhetorical argument so
rhetoric
and logic are connected when you make
appeals to reason you're using logos and
i think he gives us
good
measurable reasons to consider why it
might be worth calling this techno
feudalism instead of techno capitalism
because it clearly we've got a clear
definition of capitalism i mentioned
before
and now we have
something potentially different that
doesn't run on private property and
market exploitation anymore right
so maybe it is worth calling it
something different maybe not feudalism
because that's a throwback term maybe
something else but again and then you
just get to the point well okay now
let's who gives a [ __ ] about the word
techno feudalism let's look at the
reasons he gives for accepting such as
such a symbol
let's do that now exactly i agree i
agree with all that let's do that now i
i agree with you
i just [ __ ] talk about talking
instead of actually talking okay
whatever whatever but
the thing that you're looking for i
think there is i know but we only have
like 20 minutes left we've barely even
addressed the term
the thing that we're looking for here is
uh market participation because that's
the thing that didn't exist before
capitalism supposedly existed in
capitalism
and now no longer exists but he does do
a lot of talking about what the state of
capitalism today
non-techno-feudal companies like
apple and volkswagen he brings up a lot
and the point is that
they are still in the market but because
they're just getting government handouts
to buy back their own stock then the
asset prices for everything for houses
are inflated such that there is no
market participation for
people like us who can't afford assets
because they're way too [ __ ]
expensive um then our only option is to
become the employees for data
corporations which we are currently
doing actually
yeah whether you like it or not google
tracks where you are and enriches its
software through your free volunteers
we're adding value to spotify and apple
podcasts and google podcasts
that's true i mean i will say that when
he brought up the google maps example i
have to confess that i was like
i love google maps like
and like i guess like yes of course like
i think it's a little unfair the way
they can just capture our data
on the other hand like i'm old enough to
remember
being like like a young teenager or like
like like 11 12 years old and like going
on on the early internet
and then back then like if there was
some software i was really interested in
atlases and maps back then and i
remember there was like atlas software
remember
it was like hundreds of it was like
hundreds of dollars
yeah no but like this was before
mapquest right so like
so this is yeah this was even before
that and i remember like the
encyclopedia britannica or like in carta
microsoft and cart dude i killed [ __ ]
weeks on encarta 95. and it and so those
things they might have had an atlas and
i remember being like oh man and i
looked and it was like 300 400 and it's
like
and then all of a sudden google maps
came out and it had like satellite views
and i was like i can just look at this
for free
like i understand that our data is being
captured but it's not like they're not
giving us anything back in return i mean
i love google maps i was like a big map
nerd there's a reason i studied urban
planning as well for a little while so i
get it like it's they're taking
advantage of it but it's not like we're
not getting anything like that is i mean
i i consider it to improve my everyday
life it does
that's like sort of solution to this at
the end is that we all
become shareholders of
these new rights that are being created
like we should we should have a right to
google maps but we should also be like
shareholders of it
or at least we should have a right to
dictate
how our own data is used perhaps own our
own data but his ultimate solution is
corporate law reforms right reform
corporate ownership that's the ultimate
solution he says he loves digital
technology he loves it he says use it
right yeah use it and improve your lives
with it but don't forget that
even though it seems like google's
giving something back to you as you as
you said are they really giving back
something that wasn't just given to them
from the in the first place are they
just giving back
something like utilizing our
infrastructures that were funded by
public money or pro or even whatever
military's money putting satellites in
space google gets to tap into all those
pretend it belongs to them and then give
it back to us as if they're doing us a
[ __ ] favor
but because of the corporate ownership
model that google exists under that
giannis says we should look at
the ownership is divided into a liquid
ownership system of shares rather than
yeah was he talking about was it clear
to you whether he was talking about that
those shares would be distributed to
like all the employees or everybody like
that wasn't clear to me i think it's
just saying one vote one share
and that's it no non non-transferable
i guess to whoever wants to buy one
right you said like let's make shares
into like library cards right they got
your name on it they give you certain
privileges but you can only have one and
you can't sell them that's that's kind
of how one of the interesting things
that he said i remember was like if you
do that
the size of these companies will
automatically go way down and he said
something like google is like 200 000
employees
yeah
but then it'll go down to like maybe 20
000 which is more and that was confusing
to me too i wasn't exactly clear about
like why that's the case i mean the
thing is one of the things i have to say
like watching this stuff
was like you know it's really compelling
like janice verifocus is super
compelling but i'm also don't have
almost any economics training so like a
lot of the stuff that he was saying
i just have no way of like verifying
whether it makes sense or not like i
just kind of have to take his word for
it that like that's gonna happen or like
that the math works out right but but to
that so i was a little puzzled
he said you can't if you have to you
can't have 200 000 decision makers it's
impossible you would never do anything
right that was 10 000 which is why which
is why upper limit
which is why i was also confused so i
was like okay so these shares are going
to get distributed
but it can't just be to anybody because
if every like so if it's limited to 10
000 then would it only be the employees
like that's what made me think that
maybe he was just talking about like
when you work for a company
you get like a share like a library card
right like because because if it's
limited to 10 000
i think we're gonna have to wait for his
next book for him to elaborate on that
thing which he said is coming out this
year hopefully so we'll have to yeah
i'll be curious we'll have to wait to
see maybe we'll do a follow-up episode
when it comes out pick up some of this
stuff again but i think the basic
argument is fairly clear and doesn't
require a whole lot of
background economic knowledge he does a
pretty good job of you know explaining
his well hit first of all what he was
doing when he was a very very brief
briefly the minister of finance for
greece
and sort of then his overall sort of
theory right he in
august 2020 when british gdp was
announced to have fallen 20
15 minutes later the london stock
exchange raised by 3
and he said that was the moment when i
thought okay this isn't capitalism
anymore this is something different
because if gdp falls then there's no way
that the stock exchange should go up
that doesn't make sense there's
something else going on there and that's
when he gives the whole 2008
explanation where since then
investors have become extremely used to
you know value falling stock markets
falling and then getting a huge cash
injection immediately after so actually
the the expectation of getting that
central bank money is what pushed the
stock market up which is not [ __ ]
because it should push the stock market
up under capitalism is real value being
produced by workers in the factories but
that's not what's happening it's a drip
feed he's saying of money from central
banks being handed to banks being handed
to corporations who use it as bills said
to buy back their own shares and
increase their own values
which reflects no production whatsoever
it reflects no value creation
venture investment like i think he
mentioned i don't know if if this is
still true but i think at the time like
he was talking about how uber still has
never made a profit um they might have
made a profit like recently for the
first time but but but like in general
like yeah they haven't made a profit
it's they've been living off of like
venture capitalist uh like kind of
infusions yeah and speculative so yeah
it's weird to you that
these investors
are are so sure that this quantitative
easing is gonna occur immediately that
they're willing to like bet their bet
their profits on it that it's that
regular i don't even pay attention to
this [ __ ] but that they can bank on the
government just injecting money
whenever there's like a bad report
that's [ __ ] crazy yeah i mean that's
that's socialism for the wealthy kind of
idea right they get exactly they get the
handouts and this leaks
again no faith in the government and he
said this uh he gave this little recipe
victor that you can probably connect
with easier than the
than the economic stuff he said if you
have a combination of [ __ ] jobs
absolutely no promise of access to
assets which was what kept us going for
so long in the first place
then no faith in the government because
the government keeps doing [ __ ] like
this
um in plain sight just because
everybody's too busy arguing about uh
ben shapido on twitter
then this is a gift to fascism this is
the exact conditions for in which
uh fascism thrives yeah i know i've see
which is ironic because it's the same
condition he said he needed to exploit
when he was the finance minister of
greece
which shows you yeah that was
interesting i mean it's an opportunistic
thing he was a politician blah blah blah
whatever but i mean it's the situation
that's created that allows
i mean i would trust janus to intervene
in such a way that would be beneficial
but then you can't trust everybody to do
that creates the openings for fascists
to create well i think a lot of people i
actually read an
article
i think it was an article i don't know i
saw something and i've seen this come up
a couple times i've seen this argument
brought up a few times and i think it
was in in reference to like the january
6th
um stuff and i the the opinion was
basically like hey we need to like not
forget that like a lot of the reason why
this is happening is the financial
crisis right that like a lot of the
reason why like trumpism and like the
rise of all this stuff like we can trace
its roots
back to
kind of like a loss of faith in like
institutional stability economic
stability
um
you know being able to just like get a
job that you can live off of like the
kind of the end of all that and i think
i mean i find that to be pretty
convincing so i i definitely agree with
that
yeah i mean 2008 was our black friday
right it was uh it was huge and it
really just
i mean for this argument
and i think i think it's quite right
that 2008 completely changed the
landscape of the future
and it created opportunities for
centralizations of wealth
which is again another basis for techno
feudalism to work right because you only
have
the central banks only need to worry
about a much smaller group of people who
hold all the money rather than having a
much more equally distributed kind of
wealth which would then
um one of the one of the main things
that he doesn't seem worried about or at
least has an explanation for that you
hear a lot on like i don't know
cnn or nbc or whatever that
inflation's gonna take over if we were
to adopt certain policies and he says we
have all the conditions for inflation
and we're not seeing any inflation
because of this whole buy-back process
yeah
yeah this is so this this is him just
countering the kind of traditional right
wing economic take is if you do these
massive cash injections you know you're
going to create all this inflation and
price everybody out of the markets
but the reason it doesn't happen is
because of hey some of the stuff we
already went over right like you know
after 2008 was there's this
proliferation of precarity and [ __ ]
jobs
going from
from what was already bad to worse in
many in many cases right we all you know
know what happened in the immediate
aftermath of 2008
um but also because wealth had become so
concentrated
in the hands of a few
um
so that
you know you couldn't
when the banks get all these cash
injections they're not gonna give them
out to as loans anymore right like
they're not giving out
i mean i get i guess they kind of are
again a little bit but they're not being
as reckless with say that like um those
mortgage lending they were doing that
led up to the 2008 credits yeah like the
the fannie mae yeah like those those
so-called aaa loans you go go watch uh
go watch the big short to learn all
about that stuff they're not doing it
anymore
the one [ __ ] thing they learn from
the financial crisis is not to give
money to regular people so regular
people will just i guess never have any
assets again for the rest of time that's
i mean that's why feudalism is a is kind
of a perfect thing that seems like the
case now with capitalism supposedly on
life support right it's just the idea
that
you know prices are actually dropping
for basic things but that like you said
the asset market prices are going up and
it is precisely because of job precarity
there's not a lot of money
like income equality has gone way down
so when the banks get the when the
central banks get the money from the
european bank for instance and then
they're going to lend it to
you know volkswagen as his example who
instead of creating a competitor car
with tesla to get break into the you
know break into the car market get their
own mock competing model out there
they're not doing that anymore right
because
people don't have the don't have the
liquid funding they don't have the
liquidity to buy any of that stuff so
instead they take the money they go to
the stock market and they buy back their
own shares and increase their share
value which increases their private
wealth as opposed to you know
you know expropriating wealth from
markets in that way so that's one reason
and then the other reason again is
private equity firms right they don't
make profits what they do is they go and
they buy a company they split it into
the service side and the physical asset
side they take loans out based on the
physical asset side and then they pay
themselves back
for that again increasing their share
value but not really increasing not
really creating any value in the in the
old sort of theory of labor sense
they're not creating any new value there
they're paying themselves they're
they're aggregating money so no new
value being created means no inflation
in in this whole situation i guess
that's my sort of normie non-economic
take based on what he said about this so
you get higher prices for things like
houses and and like that sort of stuff
but then you get labor problems that
prevent people from breaking into those
markets so it's just the pattern that's
going so life support just means you
know yeah exactly no prospects for the
future until something radically changes
and then
and plus since all the value is in like
physical assets and then bonuses to the
ceos then the company
doesn't have to pay taxes because they
didn't make any profit yeah capital
gains tax there's no capital gains
so it never goes back to the public
plus they can hire you know drivers or
delivery guys as like
uh cheap contractors that have to use
their own cars
for their job
and without having to pay any benefits
of it so
nothing ever returns to
the public it just gets siphoned
increasingly towards the top it's a
corporate bank account give himself
bonuses yeah he was saying you know some
of these corporations have huge savings
accounts now they've never had that
before what like why is that normally
when they make money it's already spoken
for right because they have these sort
of you know on-demand shipping and
really tightly coordinated supply lines
so that money is usually just spoken for
right as soon as they get it it goes
back out generates some new transactions
right but now because again with kovid
too
the supply lines have broken down the
futures markets are all backed up
and whoever bought the
next wave of say transportation space or
the rights to access a certain market
whoever has those
those those
that privilege is being pushed back into
the future and so you have buildups of
products you have buildups of savings
accounts that never were there before
and you have these like sort of private
equity strategies that
facebook is doing to say in the national
health where they're just taking money
right out of the system without giving
any back in the form of taxes so you
don't have inflation
in the way that we would normally expect
it to happen when you just print money
and devalue currency and those sorts of
things because
because the because again it's operating
according to a new logic not late
capitalism but early early
techno feudalism
did you see this i had a friend uh this
week actually and she bought
a car
like off a lot and it was a used car
the the lot called her back
um and said we want to buy the car back
for more than you bought it for
and i was like what the [ __ ]
what what is happening so i looked into
it
the cost for used cars in canada has
gone up like
30 to 40 percent
because there are no new cars because of
the supply chain disruption because
again this thing was timed so that they
didn't have to have any storage space
for like the parts of a car and whatever
so the chip shortage now you don't have
this one part that you're 100 dependent
on
now everything is just sitting around
and you can't make new cars the price of
used cars goes up to the point that
someone who just sold it to you wants to
buy it back because they realize they
undervalued it it's just so [ __ ] also
i cannot get my goddamn video card yeah
still video cards are
i am a video editor without a video card
they are completely out of reach
same with things like phones right i
thought i thought stuff was going to get
so much better when canada passed that
law where they weren't allowed to lock
phones anymore and that i was thinking
oh it's going to create this huge market
of used phones and everything's going to
be cheaper nope that was all [ __ ] up
that that that evaporated after 2008
that possibility i'm guessing but even
more so with covid and the supply line
disruptions but that system between sort
of 2008 and tooth and well and the
emergence of the pandemic
that was sort of working
and not really creating any inflation
and then the supply line
disruption really just kicked everything
into the like
first gear and now it's like
now it's just now it's just all going to
the [ __ ] and and now we have to ask
questions like okay so how do we get out
of this what's next
there's one more thing i wanted to uh
bring up to bring up just to uh conclude
this a little bit at the end zizek and
he sort of agreed on this point and that
was about rhetoric with china so if i
can recall it correctly
you're going to hear
and you already are hearing uh with
trump and even with biden i think
i haven't been paying attention to be
honest but i think the rhetoric is going
to increase that you know cold war with
china china is going to be the enemy
etc etc
and they kind of warn against this which
is a something i've never
thought about before and i don't have
enough knowledge to think about but i'll
just repeat what they said basically
you're going to hear rhetoric about
increasing antagonism
with china
and that's because the business
interests that control the united states
big tech and wall street are not allowed
into china
and that's why they are competitors
because there are no tech companies in
like
the eurozone really that can compete
with google and facebook because google
and facebook are allowed there so they
can monopolize it but china doesn't let
them in so they have these actual
good competitors um
i don't know what they are weibo alibaba
those
i think those are two of them but they
have actual competitors
that wall street cannot put their money
in so the source of this antagonism the
material source
long back in the chain
is that
these are competitors to u.s financial
interests and then we get it trickled
down in the rhetoric that's saying we're
going to have a cold war with china
and then all the anti-china rhetoric is
actually based in that financial
lockout or that financial engine yeah i
mean it was a really interesting
point
i mean i i really sympathize with
the people who listen to this and sort
of you know
they look to china as a kind
of possible alternative model to sort of
american capitalism
but i mean obviously as a as a
politician he kind of says you know of
course we have to say
you know the authoritarianism of the
chinese regime needs to be called out
and opposed everything that goes on with
the uyghurs and the student protests in
hong kong and the ridiculous situation
around taiwan all that stuff needs to be
criticized but we have to remember that
china is not an imperialist country it
never has been it's never held colonies
it's never even been colonized in its
entirety only little pieces of it have
been
so it's not a colonial power so what it
does is like you said it engages in
mutually beneficial trading as opposed
to sort of the predatory kind of
capitalist techniques that america uses
right and so trump started this and
because you know the eurozone is is what
he called a investment desert for big
tech and big tech is the future
of you know profits
we think so
who has the only competitors china right
so trump started this war with huawei
which was held which whose leader was
held in a canadian prison for quite some
time which is kind of strange they
wanted them expedited to
america all that [ __ ] biden's continuing
it not changing course actually doubling
down on it because they want financial
control of
you know china which is cut off from
wall street and they want control of the
big tech market which china again has
cut off so they're going to say well
we're just not letting china build
infrastructure anywhere and not in
europe because they don't invest let's
go to africa well we have to we have to
get china out of there and we have to
build our own infrastructure because
they're going to spy on us which they
never do
well
i know in i can't remember which country
it was in but it's an african country
china came in and offered to build this
giant
like governmental
center
for a pan-african
kind of uh governmental organization
and they mic'd the whole building like
the whole building was biked up not that
this is a thing to uh
to hold against them as opposed to the
united states because the united states
been doing that [ __ ] everywhere in the
world for
for 60 years but
mutually beneficial we'll say it's a
little bit one-sided but what they did
say in at the end of this uh
talk was that leftists should not be
like
blindly pro-china but they should look
to those progressive elements in china
that will inevitably rise up i think it
was jijek who said inevitably in a true
hegelian manner that eventually there's
going to be progressive elements up in
china
but yeah you know
the changes in the means of production
will ultimately come into conflict with
traditional relations
social relations that's right they
called them a confucian right-wingers i
guess
i have no idea about the politics of
china but that's interesting that they
we got our
our religious fundamentalist
conservatives and they have their
confusion conservatives yeah that's
that's one thing to look for in 2022
very carefully anyway is the rhetoric
around china and this whole cold war
thing is is it's
not it shouldn't happen it's got to be
stopped it cannot be in a cold war a
potentially hot war but another
interesting thing that they pointed out
too was the pres the president
of china uh said xi said that
china is going to lower its growth
target in 2022
they've engineered all of this growth
china has been a
massive success in pulling people out of
poverty but now they're finding that the
growth rate is creating class conflict
with the with those right-wing sort of
chinese capitalists and so she's going
to step in and lower the growth rate
target so that that class antagonism
fails to sort of you know get too bad
and that's part of the sort of
progressive element that he was
referring to in in china is that these
progressive elements aren't going to be
contained
by this sort of american aggression this
sort of aggressive investing strategy
it's not going to be contained
but again this sort of
they also mentioned that the
the model of china is not sustainable
but we'll have to see
what the future brings none of us are
really qualified to talk about
markets and global exchange but we are
kind of qualified to talk about rhetoric
so
being fanatically pro-china or being
fanatically anti-china both of them are
are probably wrong
yeah you got to be critical but also
open i guess you say
just not i'm going to be looking out for
that that anti-china rhetoric and where
it's coming from because i i've never
heard this kind of articulation before
that it's the financial interests that
are being locked out
that
somewhere are paying someone who's
paying someone who's paying someone
to
stoke rhetoric of a cold war
and of course you expect that right you
have course assume that there's some
financial interest behind everything we
hear
but also at the bottom of it materially
there's a lack of hope
yeah and i think also just a big at
least in the american context too
just like such a big disappointment with
obama right like he came in with all
this hope and change message
and then he just ended up doing
everything that those like wall street
economists
wanted same with biden completely i
think
i mean biden's in a different con like
that's not surprising though in a way i
think like
what was just it was just more
surprising in the context of obama
because i think
back at that time there was still a bit
more faith that that rhetoric would be
true you know we were coming out of
eight years of george w bush
neo-conservatism and like you know
kind of neo-imperialism to use another
uh another term right like in in the
middle east and everyone was like okay
good that era's over
now we have a progressive um who's going
to come in and deal with this financial
crisis and create opportunities
um so i think it was just more whereas
with biden i feel like everybody
who was voting for him knew that it was
going to be
you know i don't think there was any
real hope
that that biden would actually like you
know bring in something new uh whereas i
think with with obama there really was
a kind of hope
that there'd be some change there was a
pretty fire indictment that he gave
about halfway through which was equality
and justice are just
or equality and social justice are just
bourgeois claptrap and i don't believe
in it at all just appealing to your your
bourgeois conscience
and liberating people
actually requires
changing the ownership of rights to have
shares and who can own shares and how
yeah that's just he's just being a
crypto-normativist though he's like you
know these are just bourgeois concepts
but then let me make an argument that
relies on normative beliefs about like
the betterness of the world well you
don't get that i think i i don't think
liberals get the get to have a monopoly
on normative arguments it's just
pointing out
of one normative argument and offering
another normative argument that's a lot
better
well i agree i mean i agree with that i
i guess i just think that critiquing the
well i mean
underlying one of those things in an era
in a narrow way but i guess it just
seems to me that like he's arguing for a
kind of social it's
social washing right just like we have
green washing they have kind of social
justice washing right we see it all the
time especially the ways that
corporations set up grassroots movements
and fun charities and all that sort of
way that capitalism launders itself into
feeling like it's socially just and
equitable and all that [ __ ] messaging
we get
and then and then like talk about
activists picking up rhetoric then when
activists who are kind of like centrists
and pick up on this [ __ ] and go out and
say you know capitalism's good we
generally have a better quality of life
than we had a hundred years ago blah
blah blah all that all that [ __ ]
that is a direct reflection of it it's
just people parroting bourgeois talking
points it's not doing anything except
you know green washing the social
justice version of green washing
well i mean i certainly agree with that
i mean i would rather talk about
something concrete
that would make people's lives better
the way virafakis was
as opposed to just like talking about
the label of social justice and human
rights or whatever i mean yeah of course
i mean that's right
i guess more what i was objecting to is
like some idea that
you know oh we're not actually like
we don't believe in those things at all
like you can say you don't believe in
just like appealing to them that's fine
and being more specific but just to be
like
that is what he said he said it's
nothing words clap chat
yeah okay so maybe so maybe i
misunderstood what i misunderstood what
he meant
yeah that's our brief analysis of it uh
if you want to watch the full thing it's
worth watching jijek is quieter than
i've ever seen him actually
yeah that was amazing that was that was
amazing i wonder if mike was under
control or if he just developed
some self-control that
i think he loves listening to vara focus
that was the sense i got my the sense i
got was like he's like oh i think vera
focus might be one of his like favorite
people i'm here for that bromance for
sure yeah um he's pretty good at his
moderator role anyway i i thought g jack
did awesome i should meant i should
maybe i think so too they didn't
advertise this i don't think but
the progressive international is a thing
that they're both part of and i think it
had something to do with putting on this
uh talk
but the progressive international is
legit x on their varifocus is on there
uh also cornell west gnome chomsky
corbin and it is an international
organization that supports uh
organizations in in different countries
there's one
one canadian guy that i saw that was in
there too
um so it's worth following if you want
to if you want to see what the
international left is doing i think
there's a enough clout
on that
council of members
that uh
nikki nikki ashton is the canadian part
of the ndp
oh she's a member of the ndp yeah
yeah she's on there
council of the progressive international
very cool they don't have a they don't
have a patreon but i think that's uh
one thing i'm gonna join up that was
that was fun i enjoyed that and uh i
will
we will talk again soon
you've heard from us and there's a
yeah there's a lot more where this came
from on the uh
on the links in the description so you
can just watch it uh see if you agree
with our
our analysis of the neologism which i
think we all agree in this case is
fine
um neologism can be annoying sometimes
of course and uh play play academic mad
libs with your friends
i can't
vote it's fun we should do that again we
should definitely do that again just do
it to matt and not tell him what's
happening yeah that's a good idea we
should surprise matt in the next episode
with the game anyway uh good to talk to
you guys uh thanks everyone for
listening and we will be back next week
all right bye pills buy pill politics
[Music]
you